you didn't write Ohio no young nearly
but you love that song well I get a call
from Crosby I'm in Los Angeles Neal and
David are up in a place that I had in
Pescadero in Northern California was a
friend's house
Crosby call me he goes book the studio
right now get the band together get
Halverson lose our engineer bill
Harvison I'm coming down tomorrow I said
boy you sound intense what the hell is
going on he said wait until you hear
this song I said what is it he said it's
called Ohio and Neil Roley I said what
happened he said I showed Neil a
newspaper with a you remember that
famous John Philo picture of the girl
leaning over the roundabout in Kent
State at Kent State one of the students
had been shot by a National Guard four
of them yes we slaughtered our own
children yes right so here's the story
so he shows Neil this newspaper or this
magazine whatever it was he said I saw
Neil walk off with his guitar into the
woods and he comes back an hour later
with this song right Wow we had teacher
children going it was already in the top
twenty he was going towards the top of
the charts right we put out Ohio
immediately and killed our own single
because we thought it was more important
to talk about America killing its own
children than having a hit record you're
telling me that Neil Young goes off into
the woods
an hour later comes out with a
fully-formed song completely done
finished and Crosby thought the song was
so important and so good he said come on
guys let's get together record this
immediately even added out immediately
immediately Deacon was in the studio so
we could Ojai only took us about an hour
and a half the whole song was cut in an
hour
oh yeah it's a very simple song no one
does that anymore well you know would
you grace us with a little bit of Ohio
sure
[Music]
tin soldiers and Nixon cloudy we're
finally on our own
this summer I hear the drumming board ad
in Ohio
[Music]
gotta get down
- it solders are cutting us down
should have been done long ago why don't
you know
founder get on the ground how can you
run when you know
Oh
[Music]
gotta get down to it so does our
clothing and style should have been gone
No
what are you
[Music]
founder get on the
happy
when you know you know you know
[Music]
ting sodas and Nixon Carly we're finally
on our own
this summer I hear they're drawing for
daddy in Ohio for daddy no why
for Danny
[Music]
while that is one powerful song